why is it that the islam became
so much a problem for us why
yes you know
the problem was the a mass immigration
why this social and political
problem became a religious problem
and the terrorist
problem i think because there were
two main ways to cope with this
problem of mass immigration
one was to to try
effectively to give
all the rights of citizenship
to the new uh to the new
people uh coming in
but this means
to enlarge welfare state
this has a big cost this
means
this was also i think for for the left
an opportunity the other
way was not to
spend money but
to give a sort of recon recognition
to the cultural difference
but cultural difference and rights of
individuals are two completely different
things
and you can respect
a different culture where individuals
are not respected within
it and this is the politically correct
ideology i think that
the main mistake maybe the capital
error of the left was to choose this
second
way multiculturalism
consider the extra communitarian
immigrants
as a group protect the culture and the
values
of groups but this can
become the safeguard of illiberal and
anti-democratic habits and
this was the case i think in in
europe because max wrote an essay on
on the on the axis of islamophobia
um and and and and paulo already
you know explained something of how we
came into a stage of islamophobia
why is that you use the term
islamophobia
why not simply speaking about fear of
islam
i don't i don't actually like the term
islamophobia the same way i don't like
homophobia people who attack homosexuals
and muslims are gent
are probably not afraid of them it just
seems to be a common word
um and if we're talking about american
islamophobia
it's really what it takes the form of an
attempt to institutionalize
anti-muslim attitudes attitudes that are
sort of unfamiliar to the american scene
and which didn't necessarily emerge in
the immediate wake
of 9 11.
and and so i talk about an organized
campaign to bring this campaign to bear
um in the united states it's simply
impermissible
to use anti-semitic language in public
and because of the civil rights movement
it's generally impermissible
to use racist language about african
americans or to run a political campaign
on the basis of that
so in many ways islamic islamophobia
serves as a ventilation mechanism
for the right and for people who oppose
muslim immigration
to express anti-semitism and anti-black
anti-minority attitudes in a different
way the language is incredibly
similar so why are we seeing this
phenomenon now
why is um gert wilders hosted um at
ground
zero to large crowds why are we seeing
um
this campaign against mosques in the
united states where the site of mosques
you're even
torched why are we seeing an attempt to
intimidate
second generation muslims on college
campuses and
forbid them from acting out their
identity in the form of political
activity
i really trace it to barack obama's
election as president
barack obama does come from uh he's in
indonesia right now a muslim country he
has
sympathy cultural familiarity with
muslims and the far right looks at this
as a
as an extreme threat when barack obama
was campaigning a line from one of his
books
became sort of part of his campaign and
part of his identity he said i serve as
a blank screen
for people to project their aspirations
on and so the left did that and i think
in a very naive way imagine that he
would be their messiah
but the far right projected their own
demons onto barack obama
portrayed him as a crypto muslim
manchurian candidate who was going to
install
sharia law secretly in the united states
they portrayed him as a nazi
at the same time as they portrayed him
as a socialist and they were never
called out for these contradictions in
these smears
the campaign built up and we see it now
actually we've seen it in the midterms
many of the republicans who won
election in the congressional midterms
used islamophobic appeals to win
election
the word phobia is crucially important
i would not give it up at this point and
to me the word phobia is important
because of its opposite the opposite of
phobia for me
is not moderation or love even the love
between the turtle and the hippopotamus
which
in this wonderful story you gave us for
me the truly interesting dichotomy
is between phobia and fear
and we are talking about a crucial
difference
which is for me also an israeli european
difference despite the similarities
between fear and phobia in my country
some people who have been oscillating
towards the extreme right unfortunately
in recent years
are moved by genuine fact-based
history-based fear you could critique
their response to this fear but it's a
real fear which is based
both on 100 years of real
on the ground conflict between jews and
arabs
whichever way you look at its origins
it's real and it caused
tremendous agony to both sides and
tremendous existential fears on the
jewish side
coupled with the real fears that my
people have
with your ghosts rob because what we
have in israel
now the rise of the right is not a
duplication of europe's ghosts it is
an outcome of euros ghosts which have
never died for us which are not coming
back for us
they've been around all the time we
never trusted europe so much that we
thought it's ghosts were dead
only asleep perhaps in the previous
decades but never dead so we are not
surprised but having said that
i think that the real distinction here
is between people who entertain
fear which is real and fact-based and
should be
dealt with if possible but by not by
extremism
as opposed to people who are dealing
with phobias
who do not have the right to express a
real fear and i think many people in on
this continent
have not in the foreseeable past
experienced anything from the muslim
world
which justifies hostile fear
and this is where phobia comes in
including islamophobia
with which some people are dealing very
deftly
islamophobia is irrational
fear mostly not only we had attacks in
london and madrid
but it is mostly irrational and
irrational fear is phobia
i think that phobia and and fear are
both important and
the reason why the nationalist populist
racist rhetoric can work is not because
based on
real facts but because based on
illusions and
it can work because we live in a fierce
society we live in a
hate society and anger society even when
people
frustrated about their unfulfilled
aspirations fearful about their future
perspectives and lacking
self-confidence inability to
to change present conditions and and
realize
a better future they they need
quick they need for for their anxiety
they
they need to find simple
simple explanations and quick quick
answers
so this is why nationalists and populist
politicians can can simplify
problems externalize responsibility
pick up a joint enemy and construct
a mystic community of like-minded people
an exclusionary community and
and launch a fight against these these
enemies these enemies can be
islam and can be the jewish community
or the wrong community it depends
whether we are in western europe central
eastern europe
but it functions because it gives an
opportunity
for people who are frustrated to to
express
their aggressive impulses
and they are convinced that they can do
that because they are convinced that
they are on the side of
uh morality on the side of justice
and the others are on the side of the
evil
and uh what is wrong so this this black
and white thinking this all and
all or nothing uh way of thinking is
what
drives uh politicians and their
followers
and their behavior and those to to
extreme
i would like to give a short remark to
islamophobia still
i come from hungary and that's why i was
sitting silently during
this discussion uh because in hungary
there is no islamophobia
because of simple fact that the
number of islamists living in hungary is
zero however
so there is no islamophobia but there is
a kind of islamophilia
in hungary there were the first signs of
this islamophilia
were in the 1991's
so under the attack against new york
and many people in hungary felt like a
kind of
schadenfreude and
since then in
printed newspapers on internet sites or
also in public discussions
the islamophilia
appears as an issue as a as a common
theme
and this is an encoded this is a very
nasty
encodement for anti-semitism in hungary
so you don't thanks first to the panel i
thought it was really interesting
and i especially liked um the remark of
professor
salzberger between fear and
phobia because i think in this
distinction
lies also what we need to address in
holland there
there is fear we should acknowledge that
it comes from a particular group
and a large share of that group has a
particular faith
now that doesn't mean this correlation
is causation
gert wilders does he he puts it together
and causes a phobia in that sense
to my mind what is up to the big
political parties is to
explain this distinction but they don't
seem to seem able to do so
and my question is why is that why
is the political system in holland not
able to clearly explain
this is it because there's no place for
nuance
in public debate in political debate and
if so
how come we're in a society where people
are ruled by fear
and by phobia and not by intellect
i like it very much your question i
think what has happened with
holland has happened in many european
democratic countries you were not
you were not prepared for the bombs for
the political killings
you had reached a kind of consensus that
gives you
that gave you a great social stability
uh so you you had the feeling
that you had reached a level
of uh let's say civilization in which it
was unthinkable
political killings uh political
fanaticism
the cruelty that is behind terrorism
so when this happened in this
civilized enclave
you could not respond and you became
well confused
and a bit terrified and when
a society becomes confused and terrified
tends to act irrationally to to
abandon rationality and i think this is
what has been happening with the
scapegoat
the immigrants as responsible as the
main
origin of this disruption of
civilization that terrorism means
i think this is what is happening that
is what is and if
in besides the
the political killings and terrorism you
had a
economic crisis that has produced
insecurity
uh unemployment and well you
i think this is the kind of
circumstances in which rationality tends
to
disappear